hello and welcome to this video playing
backup 24 and it seems that he is really
out for a fee Aikido him play d6s on
everything instantly came let's develop
it could be a modern yet is a modern
defense with e5 hmm and yeah 93 or the
capture I have played both this is
something that I have looked at for ya
for ages what can play it simpler than
something stuff with age for I one day
i'm actually already this age for here
or castle i think i can also castle i
know i want to play in a in a more
restrained way he takes f this Bishop
takes default I'm not so great so let's
capture I wonder if he takes with the
bee pollen if I have something good they
normally take with the night in this
position okay he took with the beep on
maybe just Bishop to d4 all right yeah
takes take c5 maybe and then some F for
business and I k i'm not sure how how
great that is so let's go for that
hmm okay and that I did not really take
into account okay I have to take what
now some samsung something with if I may
be Bishop here actually that makes lots
of sense threatening a five and I'd like
to go pawn to f4 to a pawn to e5 that
would be really nice maybe here I like
if i can get it back later oh I stumbled
right into that [ __ ] that's what was
very stupid and I actually thought about
this for one moment and then I forgot
about it huh offal
my it's pretty terrible okay 94 coming
and I have to play a rotten move like
that and now the position is completely
passive some passive nonsense instead of
just being better okay
yes Bishop d7 even coming I mean
22 was absolutely dreadful what a bad
move
awful now you can just win win win a
porn if he likes but at least then I'm
rid of that that [ __ ] that night it
doesn't go for that maybe that's a
better choice now I just wants to keep
the pressure on just probably not a bad
decision yeah I can I just try something
it would be fun it totally sucks Quincy
to ridiculousness hmm ok check ok I'm
actually quite happy about that it might
be Wow all right no I thought he had he
just could have killed me in the middle
game I mean this is pretty pretty bad as
well but oh no it gets maybe interesting
even my is so bad it's probably still
better but I was really thinking I get
shake made it quickly and it doesn't
look like that anymore it's got to be
born on c7 and my know some some chances
him
cake in 35 it doesn't it doesn't bother
me much let's go there looking over to
e2
g4 I mean I will take c7 at the end
that's no good g4 no time warning check
ok check the a porn is pretty weak
alright if you placed your phone I'll
take twice take c79 them going for now
maybe you can go G for now not sure how
bad this is however and three rookie one
okay let's go behind the whole thing
here give checks from the back
check check am i worse here hard to
believe so I can think it's probably
still wrong check check I was actually
that was kind of unnecessary really
anyway and the time is the problem I got
somebody there for now which she didn't
do
okay now he will win on time and he has
some justification of course he has a
pole at least check yeah when you have
three seconds that's not not doable and
it's lost on so yeah anyway where are my
things there was a terrible game from
start to finish I played Quincy to was
ridiculous then then he squandered all
this advantage away and I should never
lose this game Chang Here I am i
actually just met earlier and I should
should I should absolutely not lose how
to play that Kenya three rookie rookie
seven I can go look f7 you're just
winning that porn ridiculous it was a
very stupid decision and add some time
there I was really badly played I know
maybe I relax a little bit too much
thinking okay it's a draw and that's it
until it is a draw but you still have to
be a little bit little bit circumspect
King g5 is a draw now anyway I don't
really take that too serious if you have
like 15 seconds and the new blitzing
around and team has this time advantage
I'd rather want to check what happened
what I screwed up them so I think this
is this seems okay I Quincy to it's just
I said Lee ridiculous what a bad move
what a bad move and yeah I just have to
play something normal Queen d2 or
something like that this was my idea to
push like this here I think if he takes
I'm actually pretty good shape I wanted
to do the same thing with the Queen on
c2 but I absolutely forgot that this is
a possibility and he's of course having
this and it is unplayable the position
is really really really awful yeah yeah
it's just terrible here you should just
kill me in the middle game they have got
to something that going to the end game
isn't a particularly great idea is
better of course but it's a thought he
can just keep things on the board and
and then just kill me yeah like g5 for
example how I hmmm I'm not going to
survive that I don't see how and then
P&G for whatever that it looks bad yeah
I don't know sir g5 check or taking I
was surprised that he took my awful
bishop for its great night and yet most
of blacks advantage he has already
already given away but we're still
reasonably complicated okay thanks for
watching